[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احب اعرف كم حد هنا مره بتجربه الجسمي
عندنا
[موسيقى]
هي كده كده بتختلف من اي شخص يعني من شخص
للتاني في ناس بتمر بالجسون بان هو مجرد
كابوس مجرد
ضربات قلبها
او قلبها بتزيد او نفسها بيكتم في ناس
بتحس حرفيا ان جرثومه
وفي ناس تانيه بتحس بالستربس
في ناس تانيه بتحس بالسترس بتاع كويتشر
داخل معاهم بالفعل في البيت روم بتاعتهم
وبيحسوا
بنفسه وبيحس ان هم بيكلموه في حد بالفعل
قال ان هو حس ان هو دخل كيتشر عليك وحس ان
هو اتكلم معاه فهي تختلف من شخص
وبتختلف من شخص ثاني برده في يعني في ناس
بتحصل لها
مره وخلاص على كده لكن في ناس تاني بيحصل
لها تمام بيحصل لها وتصحى وتنام تاني
وتصحى تستعيد من الشيطان تقرا ايه في
الكرسي وبرده ما فيش اي فايده انا شخصيا
كانت لما تحصلي الليله اللي كان
يحصل لي خلاص
النهارده لما يفضل يستمر معاه الموضوع ده
لحد ما المنبه كنت بادخل في حدود الساعه
12:00 بالليل او الساعه واحده ويفضل يستمر
المعاد الموضوع اقول اكيد الساعه دلوقتي
الساعه 9:00 الصبح خلاص انا هقوم في
الكليه بلاقي الساعه بلاقي بقى
بلاقي الصعب حواليه واحده
ونصف بتحكي منتس لان التايم بالنسبه للشخص
اللي بيمر بالشلل النوم ده الوقت بيتوقف
حرفيا
طيب انتوا تفتكروا
انتم تفتكروا ان الموضوع
زي ما بيقولوا ولا الموضوع ليه سيتفق اكسب
مين مفكر ان هو موضوع كده
[موسيقى]
هو كتير بتقول ان هو
انا شخصيا برده يعني بشبع اكتر السوري
اللي هي بتاعه
لان انا لو صدقت ان الموضوع ليه علاقه
بالدين انا مش عارفه انام ثاني خلاص يعني
بس انا برضه هنحكي
الفلفل دي دي اويلنج بتاعت سويف اسمه
هنريك
نيرسز
هير موف ديسبرين
[موسيقى]
وهي اكتر صوره معبره عن الاحساس الواحد
بيحس في
الفتره
تفتكروا ان الاحساس الاغتنام ان انتوا
بتحسوه ده حقيقي اصلا
دي اللي هي هلوسه الدخيل اللي هو انا بحس
ان في الاوضه بسمع كلام حد تاني وده بيكون
بسبب اللي حصل عندي
اللي هي المسؤوله عن انا بشوفها الوسائل
معينه الهلوسه التانيه اسمها
دي اكتر واحده كنت بحس بيها اللي هي
انت بتقول دي اسمها هلوسه الطفل لو انت
بتحس حرفيا ان جسمك بيطلب دي بتكون بسبب
اللي حصل عندك
الهلوسه الثالثه ودي اخر واحده اللي هي
تشيسميشن يعني انت بتحس ان قلبك بتزيد
بتحس الضغط على بتحسي يعني بالم رهيب وده
بيكون سببه انك نايم بقى
وبكميه نيجت انيرجي اللي مش طبيعيه وانت
نايم زعلان بسبب مواقف معينه او نجح مع
حصلت مثلا في اليوم فدي بتكون سبب ان انت
حصل عندك
طب انا دلوقتي
حقيقيه لا انا جربت برده الموضوع وقلت دي
كلها خلاص انا هاصحى من النوم ما فيش اي
مشكله لا بيحصل برضه نفس الموضوع
طب حصل معايا الموضوع ايه الحل هو للاسف
ما لوش علاج بس هو انت بتحاول تبقى افرم
عليه بتحاول تعمل كوبينج لما يحصل لك
الموضوع ده حصل معايا مريت بالاكس انا
حاليا
اول حاجه بحاول اعملها على طول ان انا
لازم اتحرك لازم اتحرك اي حاجه في جسمي
علشان الزياده خالص لجسم دي مسببه السليب
او التشنج ده بيتفرق وهو بيكون اسمه ده
اول حاجه بتتحرك عندي لما بحاول اصحى من
النوم بسبب
صدري يا اما بحبط يعني حرفيا في ناس كده
انا كنت كل مره بقوم برضو كده رجلي
علشان اعرف اقوم
فانا خلاص صحيت من النوم وبحاول بقى ان
انا ما يحصل ليش في الليله دي بحاول ان
انا ما ادخلش في الكابوس ده تاني فهاعمل
ايه الكوبنج بيكون بطريقتين يا اما تصفيه
يا اما
انت تحاول ما تكونش ده بالنسبه لك فوبيا
في ناس بتكون خايفه اصلا لما يحصل لها في
يوم تكون خايفه تنام الليله اللي بعدها
علشان ما يحصلش معاها ثاني بس اكشن هتخليه
يحصل معك تاني كلك ان انت خايف من الموضوع
واوريدي فكرت فيه كثير وفضل في دماغك ده
هخليه يجي لك حتى لو انت شخص في العادي مش
بيجيلك دي مشكله حاول ما تروح الموضوع
يعني تمام ما تفكريش في الموضوع كثير بس
هو يعني اول حاجه ان انت تتخلص من خطك من
الموضوع اصلا ما تفكرش في ان هو حاجه
بتخوف
ده حاجه مهمه من جنرال يا شباب بعينك اصلا
عن موضوع الجسور علشان السفر قبل ما تنام
ده بيساعد على حاجات كتير اصلا في نفسيتك
اول حاجه اكيد كلكم سمعتوه عنها دي يعني
ان انت
في طرق كثيره ان انت توصل للمكان او تمارس
الموجب في ان انت تعمل ميوكسيرا
وفي حاجه تقريبا كلنا في نوع ميديتيشن
كلنا بنجربه على فكره بس ممكن تكون انتم
مش فاهمين ان هو ده اصلا اللي هو بيتخيل
نفسك انه قبل النوم بتتخيل نفسك مع حد
بتحبه بتتخيل نفسك في مكان هادي مكان على
البحر بتتحايل نفسك انه يحب المومن او
تفتكروا يعني تفرحك او فتره في حياتك فده
كله بيقتل الروسيشن
ما تفكرش في اخطاء الماضي كتير ما تحاولش
تج
ري للناس على حاجه خلاص حصلت وانت مش
هتقدر تغيرها
ثالث حاجه
ودي مهمه خالص ان انت لازم تاكسد دي ار يو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]